[Music]
one of the most iconic moments in movie
history right there who has not struck
that same pose as Kate Winslet and Leo
DiCaprio and Titanic
Ivan had a poster on my wall in college
I admit it but spend nearly 20 years
since that epic blockbuster now Kate is
starring in another disaster movie and
that has the Oscar winner looking back
on her days with Leo you know I have to
be honest I think doing Titanic really
taught me a lot about thinking ahead you
know so when you read in a script Jack
and Rose run through the flooded dining
room you have to know that's going to be
five days of shooting because it was
five days of shooting so it certainly
helped me when I was reading this script
just be very realistic about what was
going to be required of us as actors
learning to think ahead we're calling
that the Titanic effect
so when it came time to shoot her new
romance disaster movie the mountain
between us with co-star Idris Elba Kate
was more than prepared to film in
freezing temperatures so I don't want to
die up here because you're too scared to
take a risk
no green-screen here the cast and crew
were actually helicoptered each day to
the peak of the Canadian Rockies I've
never had so much luggage in my life
with you know the cold weather clothing
and the boots and the scarfs and I would
have to allow 40 minutes every day just
to make sure that I had the layers right
the hot packs on you know I'd really be
prepared and I would go up the mountain
with my little backpack of my own
survival stuff and that usually included
soup for me soup for a dress and Kate
insisted on really plunging into
ice-cold water for a scene where her
character falls through thin ice it was
going to be extremely cold and so I did
know but at the same time nothing can
really fully prepare you for how cold
[Music]
Oh